and then you say that you're treated
inhumanely because it took the laces off
your kicks as you show them pictures of
your family on your smartphone
yeah yeah I'm okay with laughing
theatrically at this sorry but he's
crying though good this story
encapsulates everything that is wrong
with to use the term mainstream media
CNN certainly this is a story that CNN
is using they're trying to draw an
emotional line between you and the
people who they're displaying so they
first off let's be clear they want you
to feel guilty for believing in illegal
immigration they want you to feel guilty
and racist for wanting illegal
immigrants to be deported particularly
felonious illegal immigrants they want
you to feel guilty for them they want
you to feel guilty for that they want to
draw they want to draw the parallel that
that's bad and racist because they can
net can connect that to Donald Trump so
they bring out this piece where they
bring out people crying sob stories of
people who are being deported for the
human interest side of the story and
then they also try and hit you with
numbers to make the economic argument
that well you know what this doesn't
even make economic sense all of it is
complete and total garbage let's go to
there they're set up it's called ice air
an airline funded by the US government
and run by Immigration and Customs
Enforcement a fleet of commercial planes
flying deported immigrants out of the
United States each passenger costing US
taxpayers an average of $2,000 last year
you say that like it's a bad thing haha
I can't I can't fly to London from New
York business class to $1,000 and it
also makes it seem a whole lot different
by the way in the spirit of being
balanced this is not how ice air sells
it in their commercials somewhere high
above the clouds Liza's simple truth
the dream to travel worryfree were
delayed overbooked flights are a distant
memory we're lost luggage is a lost
problem where you can sit back relax and
let us do the planet because this dream
has only one destination you've arrived
that dream is ice air ice air welcome
home
[Music]
the exact right time in turn for editing
that I'll give you that one
my gosh E&M you were lazy with this one
the cost of deporting them 2,000 per
illegal immigrant okay on average
according to Heritage Foundation illegal
immigrate a little immigrants burden the
taxpayer with fifty four billion dollars
per year that's about $5,000 per
immigrant so hold on so let's do that
math I think a one-time cost of two
thousand seems to be a better deal for
the American taxpayer than $5,000 for
prorated forever that's not even a
that's not an investment at a point
that's just a bargain it's just a
bargain there the jean-claude van damme
of illegal immigrants you just scoop
them up in the bargain bin exactly toss
them in the checkout but here's
something else that's interesting to me
because a lot of these people not all of
them are felons people have committed
felonies well I get I don't know if
coming here illegal I don't think that's
a felony I'm not entirely sure no but a
lot of these people have committed
additional felony so let's add up the
cost on the taxpayer of $5,000 Pierre
the average cost of incarcerated a felon
is thirty thirty two thousand dollars
per year so now we're at thirty seven
thousand dollars per year for an illegal
immigrant who's committed a felony and
these by the way are getting there in
the express aisle to be deported right
now okay
$2,000 seems like pocket change about
we're all people talking about
overcrowding
we're all the people who the pothead
saying our prisons are overcrowded in
the military the military prison for
perhaps that industrial complex okay
well good we're trying to meet you
halfway
we don't want to crowd our prisons with
people who have no business being here
in the first place let's send all over
to Mexico they probably won't to
incarcerate them we know that but we
won't have to deal with them can we find
some common ground here no the numbers
don't add up and that's why they try and
reinforce their argument to make sure
that you feel guilty and you feel racist
by turning the tears up to 11 with their
personal interest story let's give you
some examples at CNN thinks is putting
their best foot forward when Trump says
bad hombres yeah ma DUI that's what they
got me with
I was never selling drugs David Padilla
is one of 135 Mexican nationals who
arrived on this flight from El Paso to
Mexico City
it's a scene repeated three times a week
year-round yes hey didn't sell drugs he
just committed a DUI
was that a my is that a minor offense no
Mothers Against Drunk drivers isn't a
thing also all of a sudden because their
their their skin has slightly more
melanin were we're gonna down law he
just had a DUI
well first off he came here he illegally
crime and had a DUI DUI de bois de
Blasio doesn't even want to deport
immigrants with DUIs
we're talking about a city here that
wanted to ban big gulps but mr.
Hernandez driving on a case of Corona as
well Oh we'll look that slide because
we're tolerant I don't I don't know what
kind of a spacetime warp I've jumped
into twenty-eight drunk driving deaths
per day that's over 10,000 last year in
2016 so this is the SOT these are the
sob stories that they want you and they
want they roll this and they want you to
feel like a horrible person for laughing
out loud and sing good of course let's
go to their next clip just so hard they
just pull you away you can't even say
bye to anybody
so hard kind of like all those families
who never got to say goodbye to the
people who were hit by people who were
driving under the influence next clip I
would have been like pulled over the day
that happened without Trump being in
office I think I would have been able to
go home well you know what okay the man
has a point here he's saying if you know
under Barack Obama I would have been
pulled over with a DUI and would have
been allowed to stay you know what I'll
take your word for it and now he's
saying because Donald Trump's president
he was caught being in this country
illegally and committing a crime with a
DUI and is now being deported courtesy
of ice air put one on the scoreboard for
president Trump make America sober again
okay I think we have I think we have
another one here coming up there are a
few sob stories if they show no no no no
no no no no habla is no habla English
not on this show okay we don't allow
that which she's like a human being by
the who claims ice got off his shoelaces
it says none of it wise enough to keep
him from his family in the United States
okay listen the reason that we're
laughing here is so that you don't feel
guilty about laughing cuz everyone who
watched this special in a room with
friends so cry they don't you do like Al
and Bing and if you laughed
everyone out you're a horrible human
being no you should laugh as a matter of
fact you should you should laugh
theatrically that guy's an ass let me
tell you why they don't treat you like a
human being they cut off my shoelaces
they cut off your shoelaces that's right
because they don't want you to I don't
know tie someone else together I don't
know if you can hang yourself to get rid
of belts and prisons are about to
handcuff you you don't have shoelaces so
that's his litmus dip the government rip
me like a human being by the way let me
show you my family you're gonna open up
your old wallet no iPhone look at this
I'm not sure like a human being that
took the shoe laces of my kids Samsung
Galaxy seven I don't it's like you're
not like a human being you come here
illegally okay
that's already a crime not to mention
all the people you've already screwed
people who've been waiting in line
legally we have people who are trying to
get to work on this show into the
country legally as interns because they
are brilliant brilliant creative artists
and that's hard
come by you screw those people you make
the process harder then you get a DUI
which results in thousands and thousands
of deaths per year is also inconsiderate
you probably don't know how to use your
turn signal then you talk about how the
previous president would have let it
slide and so it must be racist for the
current president do not let it slide
and then you say that you're treated
inhumanely because they took the laces
off your kicks as you show them pictures
of your family on your smartphone yeah
yeah I'm okay with laughing theatrically
at this sorry but he's crying though
good it's only racist of the United
States doesn't I knew a guy who had a
DUI or maybe it was a DWI in Canada he
was coming from Europe he can't go there
for ten years this happens in every
country if you want your country
illegally and you commit another crime
they're not super lenient let's go south
of the border because learning about
people's cultures is appreciating their
cultures what are mexico's immigration
laws like now first off felonies are
punishable by two to ten years they're
pretty harsh and they're even more harsh
on felonies from people who are there
illegally they don't use a politically
correct term they don't call you
undocumented worker they call you and
throw you to the border Mexico here's
our policy Deportes foreigners who are
deemed detrimental to economic or
national interests violate Mexican law
are not physically or mentally healthy
or lacked the necessary funds for their
sustenance and for their dependents it
almost reads like a Margaret Sanger
script so let's be clear Mexico doesn't
just deport you if you commit a crime
Mexico Deportes you unless you're a
sugar daddy yes don't even think about
trying to get on the public dole you
have to be making more than the average
some railroad friend over there
otherwise they don't want you and they
send you back they send you back if you
are not in their best economic or
national interests you see that
nationalism their nationalism is only
racist when the United States does it
and you which is ultimately ironic
because we're a country that don't
really have a national racial identity
you can be a nationalist in the United
States and that's represented by the
Constitution you're a nationalist in the
sense that you believe our culture
created by the laws as for the
Constitution Bill of Rights have
fostered a culture of freedom that I
like when liberals say we have no
culture no we our main export is culture
that's why people are doing whatever
they can to get here a Maya nationalist
in the sense that I think our nation is
better than Mexico yes their nationalism
it's a race
of tiny brown people I'm a nationalist
and I think the Constitution kicks ass
and I think that it's created the best
country that's ever existed but that's
somehow that's more racist than what
they do over there in Mexico immigration
right a lot of people they have problems
amnesty okay we understand it or anchor
babies is a term used that's kind of
complicated sure the kid didn't do
anything wrong yeah and I can see both
sides that argument it's this at some
point someone has to be punished you
know you had the argument on immigration
where Trump was absolutely blasting
Marco Rubio and then his plan kind of
put forward is effectively the same as
Marco Rubio but before we even get to
you know left us always say you know
Republicans are the party of no we want
to find common ground okay let's get rid
of amnesty before you even get there or
before we even get to anchor babies I
understand that these are issues that
need to be discussed but right here
right now we are talking about deporting
illegal immigrants who are only found
exclusively because they got caught
committing crimes how is that if we
can't find common ground there there is
no common ground to be found
it's like listen okay before amnesty
before we get to anchor babies what
about just deporting the guy who got a
DUI I can't believe you there's no
possible way we could have a logical
discussion the gut okay the guy
committed a DUI three times we caught
him it's all gonna cost us two thousand
dollars can we deport him I think that's
insensitive this is why I don't say I'm
a centrist we'll have anyone on the show
and what I said it's with Dave Rubin
will argue will discuss with anybody but
I am a conservative I am very right
leading the problem is there is no
centrosome for reasonable people the
left won't meet you in the center first
place and you know why you don't want
sidered racist of the United States does
it even though we're again we're talking
about the Constitution is nothing racist
in being proud of your country it's not
like North Korea who are having
propaganda videos launching missiles
it's not like Mexico that wants to
deport you if they have the wrong shade
color of skin the reason everyone gets
all up in arms and they hate it when the
United States actually goes out there
and proudly touts their national
interest is because the United States is
the prom queen we are that hot chick who
everyone looks at and everyone wants to
be with that hot chick and the entire
world were the best woman in the room
and everyone wants to be going to prom
with us but you know what a lot
some kid people don't get to dance with
the prom queen so guess what happens if
you're ugly you see with fat pride
activists if you say I'm proud of my
body and you're fat and ugly everyone
says you're brave if you're beautiful
and you say I'm proud of my body here's
a bikini picture everyone calls you in
an uppity [ __ ] that's what happens with
the United States we're good-looking
we're successful so if we're proud of it
it's considered nationalistic it's
considered racist but if the crappy
countries that have contributed zero
zero to modern society other than some
cool decapitations that were presented
in Mel Gibson film are somehow proud of
their country we're going to allow it
your honor we want to talk about common
ground III would take it further than
that not people with duis but a lot of
these people not all Mexicans okay I'm
not saying all Mexicans are rapists but
the people who are here who are
committing rapes and murders and are
joining and creating gang violence I I
think I think you put them on an
exclusive private first class ice air
jet
hey you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if not there's a strong chance that
you're an Armenian genocide denier well
in quake I think you know what I'm
talking about but I don't over there if
this isn't the channel for you I'm sure
you'll find something there that you
deem very insightful and informative
also I request that you come back here
afterward and immediately leave a
negative comment because we read those
and those affect our lives directly we
care about them because we care about
you